from a
bad hair day to a tragic natural
disaster
wind can be a formidable foe let's just
stay ahead of the wind
but what if this powerful force just
didn't exist would airplanes still fly
how would the weather change and what
would earth
look like without it this is what if
and here's what would happen if there
was no wind
[Music]
mild temperatures pollination
long awaited rain and dry regions
you can thank the wind for these things
a clear day in a polluted city
yep also the wind it also helps create
our weather patterns and diverse
ecosystems
without it earth would be an
otherworldly
alien planet but what is wind
i hope you're a fan of weather cause
we're gonna blow your mind
wind is a side effect of the uneven
heating of earth
it takes much longer for the sun to heat
the sea
than land this means that the
air above the sea has a low pressure
while the air above land
has high pressure the contrast
of these opposing air pressures causes
diffusion to occur
diffusion is when something with high
concentration
moves into something with low
concentration to balance things out
it's the same principle that causes ice
to melt
in your drink for weather
the effect causes the different air
pressures to rush together
and this is what creates wind
wind and weather patterns are also
affected by the rotation of the earth
it's called the coriolis effect
and it makes storms swirl clockwise in
the southern hemisphere
and counterclockwise in the northern
hemisphere
why well each day
the earth makes one full rotation
but because of the shape of the earth
different points
move at different speeds the equator is
the widest part of the earth
which means a coordinate point at the
equator has a longer distance to travel
than a coordinate point in the south and
north poles
and it's a pretty large difference let's
take
this point here it travels 1600
kilometers per hour
to complete a full rotation but if we
take a point
near the poles it only needs to travel
at point
zero zero zero zero eight kilometers per
hour
or two meters per second
this is why air currents bend to the
right in the northern hemisphere
and to the left in the southern
hemisphere
the coriolis effect is how wind brings
warm weather
from the equator to the north and south
poles
and this is very important because
without this dispersal of temperature
we'd be in trouble
absent a gentle breeze or a mighty gale
to circulate both
warm and cold weather around the earth
the planet would become a land of
extremes
areas around the equator would become
intensely hot and the poles
would freeze solid entire ecosystems
would change
and some would completely disappear
but it's not just temperature that the
wind blows around
it also carries rain clouds
land not directly next to bodies of
water
would dry up and become deserts while
areas close to water
would probably be very wet places with
many rainy days
because of these extremes hot and cold
dry and wet we'd see mass migration of
people
fleeing the uninhabitable equator and
pools to the moderate in between places
this would cause a lot of population
strain for locations like the northern
us
southern canada and southern europe
[Music]
if that wasn't enough ocean currents
would be severely impacted by a lack of
wind
which would further change weather
patterns
the good news we wouldn't have any
hurricanes
these aren't costly katrina claimed
1200 lives in louisiana and mississippi
in 2005 and cost the united states
125 billion dollars
so we may not have to budget for
hurricanes anymore
but we'd still need to spend that money
or more
just to survive in a windless world
for one thing we'd have to create
massive irrigation structures
to transport water from rain-soaked
coastal areas
to sunny but dry farmland
even with irrigation we would struggle
to produce enough food and
famine would spread across the globe
but don't worry you'd still be able to
hop on a plane for travel
while planes use wind in flight
they don't need it wind simply helps
them get airborne
faster without it they'd just need to
burn more fuel
to reach the speeds needed for liftoff
wind is important to our atmosphere and
is often taken for granted
it's a case of out of sight out of mind
not only does it provide a cool breeze
during a hot day
it also creates our cherished ecosystems
no wind well there wouldn't even be the
amazon rainforest
and since the amazon produces 25
of the world's oxygen it would be bad
news for us
if we lost it but
that's a story for another what if
you